demócratas y republicanos visitaron la
frontera sur de eeuu
su visita llegó con narrativas dispares
en un momento en el que el país registra
su mayor flujo de migrantes en las
últimas dos décadas para los
republicanos representados por john
cornyn y ted cruz el tour sirvió para
exponer la gravedad de la situación lo
que nos trae aquí ahora es esta crisis
humanitaria inmediata esto es la
consecuencia directa de las decisiones
políticas de la administración de byd en
preparar la construcción del muro de
volver a capturar y liberar migrantes y
acabar con la política de quedarse en
méxico paralelamente los demócratas de
la delegación del congreso vieron una
rueda de prensa tras su visita a una
instalación de acogida para niños
migrantes que llegaron solos a la
frontera sur con texas
su prioridad asegurarse de que los niños
están siendo tratados con humanidad hay
más al agua
childs
like this' que yo mismo fue una niña que
vi como estos niños de la violencia
desmesurada situaciones que creo que a
menudo olvidamos aquí en el confort de
eeuu
en el arcón first in the united states
por su parte joe biden recurrió a kamala
harris para ponerla al frente del reto
de acabar con el problema migratorio
desde la casa blanca una problemática a
la que califica de temporada ya que es
la época del año más segura para viajar